joséphine bacon coup et aouedj pauline
marois j'étais très ému par le film
je m'appelle humain de kim o'bomsawin
c'est l'histoire de votre vie de vos 15
en pensionnat mais aussi de votre
histoire de résilience votre arrivée à
montréal où vous êtes presque retrouvé à
la rue pour enfin devenir une grande
poétesse et nous vous avez déjà dit que
l'écriture est arrivée par un accident
comment ça s'est passé l'accident est
arrivé j'ai une amie que j'aime beaucoup
et qui portent c'est elle écrit de la
poésie depuis qu'elle est auto jones et
une bretonne
elle s'appelle laure morali un jour du
puits d innover et cantiques de mingue
ans l'ont adopté parce qu'elle
n'arrêtait pas de faire des
allers-retours quand elle était plus
jeune
depuis la cueillette qui ont fini par
l'adopter elle est même allée dans le
nôtre mais avec un vieux chasseur et ses
filles
et puis un jour elle a fait un rêve l
arrêt son rêve lui disait tu es de
jumeler des écrivains poètes québécois
avec les premières nations
puissant ça a donné imitant parlons nous
on se trouve chez votre éditeur mémoire
d'encrier qui a vraiment changé votre
vie en 2009 avec un premier recueil
bâton un message et vous avez écrit ceci
dans ce recueil toi qui m'as fait
gardienne de la langue
toi qui m'a chargé de poursuivre ta
parole
je sais que tu me vois qui vous a chargé
d'être une des gardiennes de la langue
inoue pourquoi vous avez accepté cette
mission là un jour il ya un vieux qui
m'a dit tu es et tu dis aujourd'hui je
te raconte mon savoir il m'a dit un jour
ce sera ton tour et je pense que je le
fais je le fais quand même je le fais ce
qui m'a demandé de faire mais avec de la
poésie c'est tout ce que j'écris
c'était mes poètes les anciens c'était
des poètes la façon qu'ils te raconte
cdd et des récits anciens ou les art
hogan fondateur c'est à vitesse et leur
poésie qui te donne alors que c'était
des fois ya un seul mot c'est pour
enfants serez par exemple deviendrait
une grande grande foi mesures qui ont
besoin comme de sol d'un seul mot mais
qui te traduit tellement de belles
choses que tu es un mou tête tu le vois
apparaître
tu le vois des pépites souvent ce que tu
vois est homme est en verre que vous
portez du violet en hommage à georges et
chaque fois mme joyce et cette manne des
caisses
qu'est ce que ça vous dit comment vous
avez réagi qu'est-ce que vous ça vous
dit à propos du racisme au québec mais
tu vois quelqu'un je les regardais
partir en direct
tc sur les réseaux là je me disais c'est
pas possible
et quand je t'aime tu la regardes partie
t elle s'en va avec sa langue ses
penchants séquelles pas qu'il entend
parler en attikameks déjà habitués ça ma
tête j'avais le coeur gros gros gros des
charges et de larmes plein plein plein
plein de larmes et puis je me disais on
peut pas on veut pas blesser quelqu'un
ou tank sans ces dindes dans ce manque
de respect mais jeudi elle est partie en
gagnant un combat tu vois aujourd'hui la
grâce à elle
grâce à elle ce qui est des gens sont
ont pris conscience que il ya du racisme
et puis à du racisme systémique
tu vas ci vers des lumières tel un
papillon qui brûle ses ailes
les mots ont parfois l'effet d'un réveil
alors je construis joséphine bacon avec
votre poésie parce que vous permettez
que je vous lise une de vos plus belles
phrases selon moi je peux la lettre
notre public et oui bien sûr je me suis
faite belle pour qu'on remarque la
moelle de mézos survivante d'un récit
qu'on ne raconte pas
joséphine bacon jeunesse comme thème
était je me suis faite belle pour qu'on
remarque la moelle de mézos survivante
d'un récit qu'on ne raconte pas
[Musique]